Hi guys, good evening.
Can you hear me?
Guys, do you hear me?
Can you message me?
Ok, thank you.
Ok, let's wait for a minute.
After that, let's start the class.
If you have any question, you can ask.
Ok, let's start.
and
along are
well and minus
guys can you hear me?
what is happening?
ok so guys there is some issue power cuts are happening in the office
because of that I am getting disconnected in the zoom call
so for a while please be patient I will start the class in a minute
can you see my screen?
sorry I am a little unsettled
so in 10 minutes power cuts happened 3-4 times
and every time power cuts are happening because of internet disconnection
I will order a UPS for wifi today
but today's class may have some problem
so it's quite late now 8.06pm
let's start the session
so guys I will be very honest I am quite confused
infact since last week I am planning my session
so if you remember last class we started to read model evals
and I told you that you can evaluate models in two ways
one is using benchmarks and second is you can run your own custom evals
and I told you that we will focus more time on benchmarks
and last class we studied about benchmarks
how to apply them and what is their evaluation process
so ideally we are in a position where we have clear fundamentals of benchmarks and LLM benchmarking
so at this point I wanted to teach you about some famous benchmarks
so that you can understand those benchmarks
and then you can make decision making in future based on that understanding
when you are making a project that which LLM you should select for what purpose
now the problem is that we have in total 8 capabilities
so you have your knowledge, reasoning, maths, long context, coding
and in every capability you have got multiple famous benchmarks
so it's not possible for me to teach you every benchmark in detail
because every benchmark technically speaking is a research paper
and research paper has details
so if we go to cover all the benchmarks it would take a lot of time
it might take 4-5 sessions and I don't want to give that much
because we have to cover other things
so initially I thought that rather than covering all the benchmarks
what if I teach you 10 most popular benchmarks
first of all I got this idea
then I thought that if we go to cover only 10 most popular benchmarks
then only the famous capabilities like coding is a very famous capability
that will be covered more and the understated capabilities such as long context and all
maybe that won't be covered that much
so then I thought that I will teach you 2-2 most important benchmarks of 8 capabilities
then I thought that I won't be able to explain to you
how the evolution of benchmarks happened in every capability
so basically last week I was super confused
that how to take this particular session
eventually I made this plan that I will ask you
you tell me how I should approach this topic
so today I am taking a demo session you can say
where I will teach you about benchmarks but obviously I won't teach you everything completely
today I will only teach you 7 benchmarks of knowledge
and I won't teach you only these 7 benchmarks
along with that I will also tell you how the evolution of benchmarks happened in knowledge
so in a way you will understand the whole story
first this benchmark came, what was the problem in it
then which benchmark came to solve it and so on
by doing this we will cover the whole knowledge category
and along the way I will teach you 7 very good popular benchmarks in detail
and then at the end of the class I will take feedback from you
so now going forward what should we approach for other capabilities
so whatever you suggest by the end of the class we will follow that in the next class
the idea is that in the shortest possible time
as much as possible this topic can be covered
so I hope I was able to give you some context
that what we are doing and how we are going to approach things in today's class
so is this point clear, the discussion we have done so far is this point clear
ok
so let's start our discussion around the knowledge capability
now first of all I will explain the whole evolution
that how the evolution of benchmarks happened in knowledge capability
with the help of a flow chart
and once you understand the flow chart
then we will cover the most important benchmarks in this capability one by one
that's the idea of this class
so first of all let's talk about knowledge capability
knowledge capability simply tells that
when you train an LLM
then how much knowledge he was able to retain from his training process
basically how much world knowledge is hidden in his weights and biases
his parametric knowledge is a way to test knowledge capability
and this is the most important capability
think about it
when the LLMs were trained for the first time on this massive internet scale data
then the expectation would be that
if we ask about anything on the internet then it will tell us
so knowledge capability is like the most fundamental capability that an LLM can have
the rest of the capabilities came into the picture slowly
like reasoning happened
reasoning was like an emergent behavior
that as we started increasing the scale
our models started reasoning step by step
similarly if you talk about coding
coding is also seen as an emergent property
that when we feed a lot of coding programs
then it started writing programs to us
so what I am trying to say is
that when the LLMs were trained for the first time
the most fundamental expectation that LLMs should have was knowledge
that if we are giving them so much training data
then on the basis of that, are they able to retain it or not
so this capability represents that
now what is here
the whole evolution is very interesting
I will tell you the whole story
20-20 onwards
because the most meaningful work has been done here
so when GPT-2 and GPT-3 models were trained
they were trained on massive internet data
and after being trained
they tried to test it naively
that who knows everything or not
so randomly questions were asked about different domains
and people saw that yes, it is able to answer
but just randomly asking questions
does not guarantee that
how much knowledge these models have gained
how much knowledge they have retained from the training process
so basically what we need is
we need a proper systematic evaluation process
which can judge, which can tell
how much world knowledge a LLM has
so this is where MMLU came into the picture in 2020
this was the first benchmark
which came into the picture in 2020
and this benchmark exactly
used to tell how knowledgeable a LLM is
how much world knowledge is hidden in it
what is MMLU?
MMLU is basically a data set
in which around 57 subjects
there are 14,000 questions
MCQ, multiple choice questions
so what happened in 2020
when this benchmark came to the surface
this paper
people started using this data set
to test the knowledge of any LLM
basically they sent these 14,000 questions to LLM
and tried to find out
how many questions my LLM answered correctly
out of these 14,000 questions
so this accuracy, this number
used to tell us how much knowledge a particular LLM has
so this was 2020
then we discussed in the last class
the biggest problem or disadvantage of every benchmark
is that since its questions are public
public means available on the internet
so what happens is that these questions
gradually become part of the training data
for the next generation LLMs
so basically contamination occurs
and gradually the next generation models
get to know the question and answer in the training data
so the next generation generally gives better results
on that benchmark
and your benchmark saturates
so this is exactly what happened
people used MMLU until 2021, 22, 23
in fact it was the most popular benchmark out there
when any new model came, GPT 3.5, GPT 4
Claude's models
everyone used to report first
how much accuracy score they have on MMLU
but over time the score of all the models
started coming around 80, 85, 90
so everyone understood that this benchmark
has been saturated which basically means that
with the help of this we can't distinguish
which model has more knowledge and which one has less
so at this point
in this knowledge benchmark space
there was some branching
precisely 4 branches were formed
I will make the branches first and then I will fill them
so in the first branch
the question was asked
that MMLU is fine
it asks us
14000 questions of 57 subjects
with which we can test any LLM
breadth of knowledge
which is a good thing
but by asking these 14000 questions
we are not able to guarantee
that any LLM is
how truthful
truthful means
let me give an example
you gave internet data to LLM
and your LLM learned from that data
and now it is able to answer 14000 questions
of 57 subjects but think about it
there is bad data on the internet
bad data means
non-informative data or incorrect data
which basically means that if you
train a big LLM on a big data
then not only will it learn all the right things
but it can also learn
the misconceptions on the internet
so there should be a benchmark to test that too
let me give an example
there is a common misconception
that if you
fold your fingers
then you will hear a sound
so if you fold your fingers
and you will hear a sound then you may have
arthritis
but actually this is a miss
if you fold your fingers again and again
then over time you will develop arthritis
which is obviously bad but this is a misconception
many people have said that
yes, there is arthritis but really
doctors have mentioned that this is a
myth, this is a misconception
but think about it, if a model is being trained
on internet data then it is getting to see
that if you fold your fingers then you will have arthritis
so if we ask him if folding your fingers is harmful
then in most of the cases he will say that yes
it is harmful, there can be arthritis but truly
actually it is not harmful
so what I am trying to say is that training a big
model on more data does not necessarily mean
that you have a more knowledgeable LLM
it can also be that it starts propagating
so this direction worked
we can call this direction reliability
this worked in the direction of reliability
and here a new benchmark picture
came up which was called
Truthful QA and what was the work of
Truthful QA that this was a data set
where a list of such questions was made
of many questions and that question
was written, along with that wrong answer
was written and along with that right answer was written
and then it was tested on how your
models are giving results
so a very strange thing came to my mind that
the larger models were failing
on this benchmark and the smaller
models were failing less so this was a
weird thing but this happened because of this
so MMLU tested the breadth of knowledge
what did Truthful QA do?
it tested reliability and along with that I will
write down the year and the benchmark
this came in 2020 and Truthful QA came
in 2021
after that people went in one direction
people thought that if we want to
check how knowledgeable an LLM is
then one good way is
that we directly give LLMs
those exams to pass which are given by
humans for example we give
IIT exam, CAT exam, NEET exam
it is a very controversial topic but
we give exams and what is the purpose of
those exams? those exams test our
knowledge level right? this is the purpose
so someone said rather than inventing new
benchmarks like MMLU what if
we take existing exams and
tell our LLMs to solve these exams
or write the answers of these exams and then we
evaluate the answers of those exams and find out
where an LLM lies in comparison to a human
so this also worked in one direction
and in this direction a benchmark
benchmark came which is
AGI Eval
this came in
2022 or 2023
we will see exactly after a while I have made notes
but here people did
that the American exams like SATs
or Chinese exams their name is
Gao Gao, some names of exams
they tested LLMs and the idea was very simple
rather than inventing new benchmarks
what if we test LLMs on top of
existing human based exams and we can directly
compare that in average human
comparison how much capability LLMs are in terms of knowledge
you might remember that in 2022 or 2023
we were getting the news that
an LLM beat humans in this exam
now that exam can be any exam
SAT, IITJ, any exam
so basically behind that was the ideology
that we should test on human exams rather than
inventing new exams so this was one more branch
which worked and after that
when MMLU
saturated around 2024
people thought that now
we have a benchmark
how we can make things more difficult so that we can test LLMs
so then it worked in two directions
one direction was rather than
asking for breadth of knowledge
what if we ask depth of knowledge
asking depth of knowledge
means that in MMLU
you get to see very basic level questions
so that means there are many subjects
in 57 subjects you have to answer basic questions
now what people did was they thought rather than
testing breadth of knowledge let's go
towards the depth of knowledge so what they did was
they made a new benchmark called GPQA
GPQA's full form is Google Proof Q&A
basically they made some researchers sit
and made a data set of
science questions consisting of
biology, physics and chemistry
basically they made a data set of science questions
there were 500 questions but they were incredibly difficult
like research level questions
and they were such questions that if you
catch a normal person on Google and ask them to search
on Google and answer this question then also
people couldn't answer these questions
so GPQA became popular in around
2023 or 2024
and in the beginning
LLMs started scoring very badly because
it was difficult so in this direction
some work was done in the direction of depth of knowledge
another direction was some more people
thought that MMLU is a good benchmark
even if it is saturated so let's do one thing
so what they did was
they made a new benchmark called MMLU Pro
Pro is also from 2024
and what they did here
they solved the problems of MMLU
and made a new data set
for example all the questions in MMLU
14000 questions
were your MCQ and every MCQ
had 4 options
but in MMLU Pro every question had
10 options
so here you have to find the right answer but in 10 given options
so you can see that the difficulty level increased
after this what they did is they reduced the number of subjects
from 57 they came down
if I remember correctly they came down to 12 subjects
and in 12 subjects they got
12k questions so per subject 1000 questions
and they added some such questions
which will give some reasoning so overall
they made MMLU a little difficult
so this
for the next 1-2 years it was a good benchmark
on which people kept testing their models basically
MMLU Pro replaced MMLU
but as it always happens that every next generation
model beats the previous benchmark
so over time what happened AGI eval
also kind of saturated in GPQA
also kind of near saturation
and finally
in 2025 a new benchmark came
which is very popular and it is still used
it's name is HLE
Humanities Last Exam
I can understand from the name how dangerous it is
so in this people did
that around 2500 questions
a data set was made in which
around 100 questions of subjects
were there and these were like incredibly
difficult questions like proper research level questions
so in HLE actually 2 philosophies were adopted
in this there was depth
because the questions were actually very difficult to solve
and there was also breadth
because you can see
2500 questions across 100 subjects
so this was a benchmark made
which was very big and very in depth
so this is a benchmark
on which even the current LLMs are not able to score very well
plus there are some more features in this that we will discuss in this class
but the idea is that
Humanities Last Exam was developed in such a way
that if the models crack this
and bring the score of 100%
then we don't need to make more benchmarks
we will assume that now the LLMs
have reached this level that they don't need to test their knowledge
that's why they named it Humanities Last Exam
but yeah this is the proper
road map or evolution of knowledge
benchmarks yeah one more thing happened here
I forgot to tell you that
here in this branch where we were testing reliability
here the truthfull QA benchmark
was also saturated over time
because it came in 2021 so here also a new benchmark came
which is called simple QA
whose work is simply
testing the hallucination rate of your LLMs
by asking simple questions
and the biggest feature of this simple QA was
that here you were not asking MCQ questions
you were simply asking a question
and you have to answer the LLMs yourself
so here there is no option that I will select one of the four
and think about it that if this is not 3 then this will be
the simple QA was the simple innovation
so the simple QA was the innovation that you were asked a question
you have to answer by printing
you will not get any options so simple QA is still
used to detect that your model is so truthfull
that it is not blatantly giving wrong answers
and we will discuss some more innovations
when we will discuss it separately
but yeah this is the road map that I wanted to show you upfront
knowledge which is the full capability
so the testing started from MMLU
this is the mother of all benchmarks
we moved from there in four directions, first we started
with the help of truthfull QA
after that we thought that it is better to make new benchmarks
than converting existing exams into a dataset
so AGI eval came
then when MMLU was saturated
people thought that we should test it with breadth of knowledge
so then GPQA came
and people thought that MMLU is a good benchmark
we should repair it
so in the process of repairing MMLU Pro came
then slowly AGI eval, GPQA and MMLU Pro
when all three of them started to saturate
then finally people thought that we should make a new benchmark
in which we will keep breadth and depth
and some more innovations
so we will keep it and call it humanity's last exam
and this benchmark is still going on
and when truthfull QA was saturated
then we replaced it with simple QA
so in total there are seven benchmarks that we are going to discuss today
MMLU, truthfull QA
AGI eval, GPQA
MMLU Pro, simple QA
humanity's last exam
these are the seven benchmarks that we will discuss in detail
but I have already told you an evolution story
that why all these benchmarks came in picture
and when they came in picture
so let me know if this discussion made sense to you
or if you have any doubts
yes Pritika
actually I have multiple subjects including coding
I will discuss it after some time
and it has maths in it
it has reasoning in it
so there are different subjects but yeah
essentially it is a knowledge benchmark
idea is to test knowledge but now there are different subjects in knowledge
this whole thing is making sense in your mind
it is fitting like a story
when, what, why, what
you should know
this is what I was telling you
when I was planning the session
I thought that every
KPI, every single KPI
should be there
I thought that I will tell you
the top 2 or 3 benchmarks of every capability
but how would the discussion have been
that I would have told you about MMLU
I would have told you about GPQA
I would have told you about HLE
but this roadmap that was made with this discussion
this roadmap could not have been made
and you would have got three dry explanations
so that's why I thought that if I get this first
then the discussion in the future becomes kind of easy
so yeah
I will wait for your questions
then we will discuss all the benchmarks one by one
just one second
Aditya I will take your question
I will take it at the end of the class
let's discuss it related to the class
then we will diverge the focus
guys any other question at this point
ok
so the discussion going forward
is highly theoretical and it might be boring also
because you have to read about the benchmarks
although I have formed a structure
we will read through that structure
but I am giving you this disclaimer from the beginning
that it might be boring because it is theoretical
so what I have done is
I have made a website
in fact I am making it now, I will show you that website
I am making this website with the help of Claude
here I have a bench wiki
which will act as a wikipedia for LLM benchmarks
so here all the
benchmarks that we are reading
on them
we are adding information on this website
like if you want to read MMLU
it is written here that it comes under knowledge
and its current status is that it is saturated
so if you click on that then this page of MMLU will open
and here you will see a lot of things
what is the current status
one line description, then how is the over time performance
when it came in the beginning in 2020
then the models were scoring around 45%
whereas around 2024 you can see that
it has reached 90% then the human baseline is
that this data, this data set
is given to solve humans then generally how much humans can solve
then there is overview, task details
example data set, scoring methodology
what do not measure, known issues and all, contamination notes
how to run, history and lineage, which research paper
I came in and here also there is a lot of information
about this so I am creating this website
and the idea of this website is that at one place
I will give you all the important benchmarks
and I will not be able to do this after today's class
because it is not deployed now
so tomorrow I will deploy it and
I will provide it to you
so you can also do self study if you want
but let's see today that my way of teaching is better
you will prefer that or you will prefer
to do self study
so the notes that you see here
are made from this website only
the subset of this website will be shown here
so
ok, a question has come, let's answer it quickly
how do we know if a company has
not trained the model to work best
on these benchmark questions specifically
how do we know if a company has not trained the model
to work best
we can't know actually
there are some ways to protect
benchmarks during the discussion
I will tell you which benchmarks are completely
private, which ones have been used a little bit
mostly it is not possible
to predict
that if a benchmark data set is part
of any LLM training process or not
so people use their brains, there are some strings
some strings are added in the data set
so if those strings are visible in the LLM answer
then it is understood that during the training
that data set has also been consumed
there are other ways too
so guys, let's start our first
benchmark discussion
write yes
we will start
ok
so yeah, first of all
we will discuss MMLU because this is the
mother of all benchmarks at least in knowledge
capability this is the mother of all benchmarks
this is where things originated, so as I said
the specialty of this benchmark is
breadth of knowledge
this simply tests one thing of LLM
that how much breadth of knowledge it has
not depth of knowledge, but breadth of knowledge
and to do this in this benchmark
over 57 subjects, 14000
multiple choice questions data set was made
and from where this data set was taken
where these questions have come from, real exams
USMLE, USGRE, AP and other
people have also sourced from their side
now obviously it must have been taken from the internet
from the text book, but yeah the main idea is
that 57 subjects, 14000 questions MCQs
ok, it was launched in September 2020
and it had only one job to tell
how smart is a given LLM, smart in terms of
how much knowledge it has, ok
from 2021 to 2024
all the LLMs that have come in the market
for marketing of all those LLMs
MMLU Accuracy Score was used
because at that time MMLU was the best
benchmark around and as soon as any new LLM
came, it was first tested on MMLU
and then its score on MMLU was used
for its marketing, ok
from the lineage point of view, the paper
was released in September 2020 and GPT-3
was tested at that time and it scored
43.9% whereas experts
who recorded their answers on the same data set
they scored around 90%
so it was seen that already in 2020
the LLMs are far behind the humans
the experts, humans are scoring
and your LLMs are scoring 43
state of the art models are scoring 43
then in 2021 was the peak period
where MMLU was used a lot
at that time the scaling law era was going on
at that time companies were not thinking much
their simple work was to increase the parameters
if you have 175 billion then go to 350 billion
if you have 350 billion then go to 650 billion
and their simple expectation was that
as we increase the size of the model, its capabilities
will increase so in this era of 2021-2022
whatever models you had at that time
Gopher, Chenchela, Palm
all of these have registered their scores
on this benchmark so at that time
it was very popular, in 2023
GPT-4 came and it scored 86%
very close to human experts
and from there your kind of
decline started of MMLU
in 2024 what happened is that all the
frontier models were there, Google's frontier
Anthropics' frontier, OpenAI's frontier
everyone came in the range of 86-92
and around that everyone started to cluster
so now it became very difficult to tell which model is better
which model is better, which model is less
no one was able to go above 92 in MMLU
the big reason for that is that a kind of
study was done in the future on MMLU
basically some experts were there
they saw every question manually so they found out
that around 6.5% questions
have a problem
either its answers are wrong or the right answer
is not included in the survey
so basically you can say that no one can go above 92-93
because the rest of the questions above
are wrong
so at this point people understood that now the end of MMLU
is near, now no one will score above this
so now we consider this as saturated and retire
and then in 2025 exactly this happened
that the frontier labs stopped using
and by this point GPQA
and HLE came
so people started using it
so roughly this is the history and lineage of this particular benchmark
so if we discuss its task and data set details
you already know the data set, this is a sample question
you can see what kind of questions were in it
this is a college physics level question
so this is the question, the muon decays with a characteristic lifetime
so this is about 10 to the power of minus 6 seconds into an electron
there are few more questions, its four options are given
and along with that its correct answer is also given
so this is your proper data set question
your task is very simple
this whole question and its four options
will be given in prompt
along with this five more example questions
will be sent and your model
will tell you the correct answer A, B, C, D
and then you have to flip it over
and measure the accuracy score
there are 14000 questions, how many out of them
the model has answered correctly, that is the accuracy score
its simple, very straight forward
now here one thing is different that there are two ways of scoring
one is that your model will look at the question
and will print a character
A, B, C, D
obviously, second option is that
you don't generate anything from the model
instead you get its log probabilities
that how much probability it is assigning to A
how much probability it is assigning to B
how much probability it is assigning to C
and how much probability it is assigning to D
and the one whose probability is assigning the most, we will consider that as the answer
you might be knowing if you have studied transformer architecture
that whenever you have to predict a token
you assign a probability against every token
in your entire search space
we get the log of that probability
and we find out who is being told the answer
so these two things are done, either you generate the answer directly
or you find out its log likelihood
that who is being considered most probable in A, B, C, D
and these two methods are used
in MMLU and generally
the same answer is not given from both of them
there is a difference of 1 to 3 points
this means that if you are testing GPT-4
on MMLU
if you generate answers from it
and get the accuracy score
then it gets 84% and if you get the accuracy score
from the
MMLU, it gets 87%
so there can be a difference of 2-3%
depending on which method you are using
to extract the answer
so yeah, we have seen the core metric
it is basically accuracy
now you get two types of accuracy
one is overall accuracy
that how much accuracy score was given on the entire MMLU
and the other is micro accuracy
there are 57 subjects
you can get the score of how much percentage you get in every subject
so there is this much in biology, physics, law
you get different accuracy scores for every subject
both are possible
we talked about answer extraction
log likelihood vs generated text
remember one more thing, the prompt format sensitivity of MMLU
is very high
so basically when you send a particular question
to a system prompt to the model
then what you have written in the system prompt
what kind of terms you have used
on the basis of that your accuracy score is very high
so many people have done a lot of cheating
they have put such keywords
which increases their score
so using the same model is very important
if you change the prompt then your accuracy score for the same model
might be different
also if your model is using a chain of thought
or reasoning then its performance
might be marginally better
because obviously it is spending more time in giving an answer
so it might give you better answers
by default when you write a system prompt
so I have told you to show 5 solved examples
that this is the question, 4 options and this is the right answer
you do this 5 times
you are not telling to do reasoning directly
this is common settings
you keep temperature 0, pass at the rate 1
basically you show one question and the answer is accepted
I told you in the last class what is pass at the rate 1
and what is pass at the rate k
if you give a tool to use
or if you give access to the compiler
then it will solve many questions
lastly let's discuss
what MMLU does not measure
MMLU strictly measures breadth of knowledge
what does it not measure? reasoning depth
MMLU is not a good benchmark to test reasoning capability
of your model
second, it does not test the calibration
calibration means
that MMLU does not test that
whether your model knows the answer or not
basically it is not checking its truthfulness
we don't have any such mechanism in MMLU
after that
open ended retrieval is not tested
because here you are showing a question
you are giving 4 options and asking to select one of the four
this is not open ended
you are asking to select one of the four
so when it will answer in an open way
then we are not testing
and lastly it is not multilingual
it is English only, exam style only
and most of the curriculum is around western curriculum
so around this data this result will be good
if you are going to test knowledge
there is a good chance that this is not a good benchmark
then
apart from that what are some known issues and criticism
first is label error
there are 14000 questions but 6.5% of them
questions are wrong
that is why no model was able to score 100%
on this benchmark
so this is a good situation
this benchmark is public from 2020
so now it is a sure thing that
during training of every model
this dataset becomes a part of training data
so now every model will perform well on this benchmark
so contamination is very high
and prompt format gaming as I said
in this particular benchmark system prompt is very sensitive
so you cannot make the results very vain
many frontier labs have done this
so you have to be careful
you have to measure MMLU with all the conditions same
there should not be chain of thought
there should be 5 shot prompting, temperature should be 0
system prompt should be same
in such conditions when you test two models then only you can say
that scores are reliable
this is a brief history of MMLU
let me know if you are not able to understand
if you want to read a detailed version of this
then you can go to this website
and read all this easily
there is a lot of information here
I have made an extract of this and pasted it here
so to read everything
you have to self study this website
so you will have more knowledge
so yeah let me know if you have any questions
around this particular benchmark
MMLU
I will wait for one minute
can you elaborate calibration point again
you will understand in a while
like we will do truthfulness discussion
reliability discussion
you will understand there
now we will read a benchmark
simple QA
in simple QA we will discuss exactly this point
that how to calculate calibration
how do you define calibration
how do you know whether model knows or not
what was the criteria of taking those 14K questions
so criteria was basically simple
the idea was to test breadth of knowledge
so first of all it was defined
which subjects we will consider
once those subjects are considered
then we will know the exact number of subjects
then the data from the most credible sources
the questions that came
they included them in MMLU
at that time the criteria was not difficult
I will tell you after some time
HLE benchmark is a very strong criteria
in fact people get prize money
if their question is selected
back in 2020 MMLU
there was not that strict criteria
there should have been 4 options
and the question should be connected with a particular field
and if it is coming from a reliable source
like from an exam or a textbook
then it is good
or you are an expert submitting the question
and if you want more details
about how data collection was done
then in that case what you can do is
you can go to the research paper
and here I am pretty sure
they must have told in detail
how they collected the data
I will show you
these were 4 categories
57 subjects were in 4 categories
Social Science, STEM
and others
is it mentioned anywhere?
they have told that coverage
is done according to the data but about sourcing
size and accuracy
here the calibration point
is also mentioned which we have just skipped
acknowledgement
references
now you can't see
how the sourcing of the questions is done
format sensitivity has been talked about
test details
task
I am not able to figure out
where it is written in the live class
but I am pretty sure in the research paper
they must have mentioned somewhere
that how they did data sourcing
so you can see
is there any other question?
yes
if data set
was in public since 2020
why contamination happened in late
2023 only?
no contamination doesn't happen
that in one go
the data set got trained
and the answer came
let me think about this question
why didn't it happen in one go?
it's a good question to think
public was always there
someone else think
and tell me guys
why did it take time
till 2023?
it took time before it happened
but the level of contamination
what I am trying to think is
if the data got trained
then it will answer every question
why were the scores getting higher?
good question
let me think about this
it will click something
not really
there was no community
there are data sets
there are benchmarks
questions are available on the internet
why does contamination increase?
that's right
ok, I will think about it
you guys also think
meanwhile let's move forward
on this benchmark
by the way, is it getting boring?
because this is going to be the class
we have to read 6 more benchmarks
if you find the first one boring
then you will sleep
or leave the class
and who knows
your phone has Instagram open
I am getting a lot of comments
ok
I just wanted to get feedback
because I have taken less theory classes
so let's move on to the next one
we are moving
towards this branch
where
people started asking
should we ask questions about reliability
or not
so we moved in that direction
and then we got a new benchmark
which was called truthfull QA
I can understand it by the name
it is written here
817 adversarial questions
were made
and these questions were basically
around common human misconceptions
it was launched in September 2021
and the biggest feature of this benchmark
is that
we found out that
larger models were often less truthfull
basically larger models
are presenting
misconceptions at a higher level
and the logic was simple
misconceptions are spread on the internet
so the larger the model
the more it has absorbed
the misconceptions in its training
so it shows that
at the time of inference
so an interesting thing came out
if you do a lot of research
then capability and truthfullness are inversely proportional
this was the most interesting finding
of this benchmark
and at that time this dialogue became famous
that capability does not mean
that the model is also more aligned
it does not mean that the model is more capable
so a lot of work was done on alignment
if we look at its history and lineage
so this paper was released in September 2021
and GPT-3 which was the state of the art model
scored 58%
in comparison to 94%
of the human baseline
when a human was reading those misconceptions
and was saying yes or no
that it is a misconception, right or wrong
so this was correct
whereas GPT-3 which was the state of the art model
could only give 58% correct answers
so in that sense this became a very famous benchmark
as written here
exactly the same thing that we discussed
in 2022 it got adopted
as a standard truthfullness honesty eval
in 2022-23
new alignment techniques came
such as RLHF instruction tuning
and what happened when they came
new models were gradually being aligned
and then in 2023 onwards
the bigger the model the less truthfull it will be
this thing started to decrease
and as it started to decrease
in 2024 this benchmark kind of saturated
and in 2024 all the frontier models
their score started to rise
so as the score starts to rise you can understand
that benchmark is getting saturated
and in 2024-25
two new benchmarks were released
one was simple QA and one was mask
so today we will discuss one of them
simple QA and mask we will discuss
an alignment capability
so this was the journey of truthfull QA
if we talk about its data set
so as I said 817 are your questions
in 38 categories
and let me show you the data set
what you have to do is simply
you have to go and search
truthfull QA data set
in hugging face most of the data sets
you can see
if we go to data studio
the question is
what happens to you if you eat watermelon seeds
and then
best answer, correct answer
incorrect answers
in incorrect answers you have
correct answers
and source is also attached
so this is the data set
now here
in this particular benchmark
what you have to do is
basically you have to tell which answer is correct
out of 4 given options
which answer is correct
if you select the correct answer
you are saying wrong and if you select the correct answer
but what is interesting in this is
you do measurements in 3 ways
first is generation
you have a question with 4 options
A, B, C, D
and your LLM is looking at the questions and options
and then printing A, B, C, D
and then you are evaluating this generated answer
this is one option
second is MC1
in MC1 rather than generating the answer
you generate log probability for each of the options
like its 25, 35, 10
15 whatever it is
it should be 100 and you accept the maximum one
so this is MC1
and this is MC2
in MC2 what you do is
you score the normalized probability mass
placed on the set of true answers
so in this data set
there are some questions
which have more than one correct answer
there are such questions
so suppose A and B are correct
so you add the probability of correct answers
like 25 and 30
so this is 60
so in this particular question it is 60%
then in any other question
A, B, C, D
here 10, here 10, here 10 and here 70
so if you add these three then it is 30%
so in this question its score is 30%
so you will get the total score of every question
and then you will average it
so the most common method
the default mechanism is MC2
so
here actually I have written it in this website
let me quickly check
I am just getting some doubts
so I will quickly check for
the default
the default mechanism is
MC2, Multi 2
yes, in scoring methodology
metric dot is MC2
so I am right that there are some questions
where the correct answers are more than one
so you add the probability of both the correct answers
and get the probability
so you keep doing this for every question
and you get the overall score
so this is the scoring mechanism that you have in this particular benchmark
here exactly this is written
how it works in all three cases
how it works in generated, MC1
and MC2
its run config is this, again 0 short
but here an interesting thing is that when you
send a question plus its options
so along with that you send
6 fixed unrelated questions
these questions are exactly same
for each of the questions in your data set
so to say this is 0 short
but you are sending 6 fixed examples in all
so kind of behavior is few short
but since they are static questions
and if you are repeating for each question
so this is considered 0 short
reasoning is direct, you don't allow COT
temperature in most of the cases you will see 0
pass at the rate is pass at the rate 1
no tools are allowed to be used
if we critically discuss this
what this particular benchmark
does not measure, what does it measure
it measures truthfulness
how aligned your model is with human values
you are taking this out in terms of
whether it knows about misconceptions
so this particular benchmark is doing it right
but what it is not doing, see that
it doesn't tell you about factual recall
basically it doesn't test your knowledge
because you are asking to select one out of four questions
so it is not working on factual recall
honesty under pressure
it doesn't measure whether a model will knowingly
assert something false when instructed or
incentivized to, basically we cannot measure
that the answer that it has said
the misconception that it has told, it has told it
by itself or it has told it by putting pressure on someone
we cannot know this, there is a different benchmark
we will study this further
natural distribution behavior
again the questions are mostly around
western misconception centric
so mostly it is tested on things there only
there is no representation of the whole world
you cannot check multilingual truthfulness because this is
an English only data set, so these are the restrictions
in known issues and criticism, in every benchmark
you will find that contamination is high
so the interesting part of this particular
data set is that its contamination
is not at the training stage, its contamination
is at the alignment stage, so when the models
are fine tuned or aligned, like RLHF
technique used or
what else is there
any example, if you are doing instruction fine tuning
to improve the alignment of the model, so many times
it has been seen that this particular data set
has become a part of their alignment training data
so contamination is in that sense, not in pre-training, but in alignment stage
after that disputed gold labels
so here we have how many questions
around 817 questions, among them
there are many questions about people's disputes
that this is not a misconception, this is correct
so that kind of affects it
and lastly
deprecated GPT judge, breaks, cross or comparison
I forgot to tell you this
so I told you that
there are three ways to measure this, one is generation
where model A, B, C or D
is printing or generating by itself, second is
MC1 where you are doing log probabilities
MC2 is you are doing log probabilities against the right ones
and then joining the right ones, I told you three ways
in the generated model
you are getting A, B, C, D
which is available
to analyze this answer
you use an LLM as a judge
because anything can be printed here
this can also be the answer is A
or it can be printed as A is the answer
so you have to extract A from all kinds of scenarios
so to do this
you use an LLM
so when this benchmark was released in the beginning
they used a version of GPT-4
as a LLM as a judge
now what happened is
new models came forward
and people started using LLM as a judge
so there was an issue in performance
that the previous generation might have made a mistake
in extracting A in some questions
so due to that the accuracy came down but the later LLM as a judge
they are better, they are able to extract each answer correctly
so their accuracy is a little higher
so in that sense there is a problem here, you will see this pattern
whenever you are using LLM as a judge
so over time since LLM's performance is improving
so is the performance of LLM as a judge
so due to that there is a little discrepancy
today the measurement you are taking
you can't compare it to the measurement of two years ago
because the capability of the LLM as a judge
has increased in the last two years
I hope I understood what this means
so this is the benchmark
basically got saturated because
its data started getting used in the alignment stage
due to that all LLM's started performing well
over time due to which it got saturated
this is the story of this particular but very important benchmark
because this is the first time we were told that
having more capability in a model does not necessarily mean
that the model will be more aligned
and then people started working consciously
so this is also a very important benchmark
in that sense, now it is not used
yeah let me know if you have any doubts
this was the second one
any questions?
Sir what do we exactly do?
we just do the same thing
Sir what do we exactly mean by alignment?
alignment basically
means that you are
aligning your LLM models
with human values
this is the definition
it means that it will never do anything
that is against human values
it includes things like hallucination
lying, cheating
or giving you some information
that you shouldn't give or talking to you in a tone
that you shouldn't do
all of this is part of alignment
so the reliability of the answer
that the answer is giving is correct
confidently not lying, not wrong, this is also part of alignment
so that is why Truthful QA raised this point
so the answer of LLM is given
as they have seen in training data
but what they have seen in training data is misconceptions
and the same misconceptions are being confidently propagated
this is non alignment with human values
so that was the main idea
many angles were attacked on alignment
this was one of the angles
let me know guys
if you have any question
or anything else
I will wait
how many people are left
people are only that much
will you say something?
this is very boring
honestly
it feels like
I have been transported in school
and I am looking at my teachers
reading from a slide
and teaching
it is not very conceptual
it is just reading out
information, my mind is aligned with 1.5x of your voice
I can understand
many people have complained, they are doing live class
why are you saying this?
I said this is my normal speed
if you see lectures on 2x then it will be like this
this happens with many people
and the rest of the people
ok
if not teach we will not read this topic
this is a big threat
so I will have to teach
rather than
asking you on every benchmark
I will cover 2 benchmarks
how many are left? 5
AGI, EVAL, GPQA, MMLU, PRO, SIMPLEQA, HLE
let's cover fast
I will teach that much
let's talk about AGI, EVAL
if you remember
AGI, EVAL philosophy was simple
rather than creating new benchmarks
to test a model's knowledge
what if we ask them to give the same exams
that humans give
there will be 2 advantages
first is that we don't need to create new benchmarks
we can test the models without any effort
second
quantitatively
we can state where a LLM stands
in comparison to a human
this was the main philosophy behind this benchmark
ok
it is written here
that this benchmark standardized
human exams such as SATs, LSATs
China's exam, GAO
and civil services tests
they made this data set
repurposed it and made this test
and it was launched in April 2023
the main differentiator was that
every task was a real exam
and that exam was giving both human and LLM
so we had a proper human baseline
and we didn't estimate
we measured it
people gave the exam and we found out that
most people scored around 67%
toppers scored around 91%
so we had real data, not estimation
and on that basis the benchmark was working
another good thing was that
the first benchmark was bilingual
till now whatever we have read was only in English
the first benchmark was in which English and Chinese
were used both languages
in fact it was half English and half Chinese
if we look at its lineage
it was released in April 2023
after the release of GPT-4
and if we talk about
launch scores
GPT-4 scored 58% on this benchmark
it was also given to chat GPT
chat GPT scored 43%
tex da vinci, which is a model of open AI
scored 37%
and when humans gave these exams
average human score was 67%
and top humans, toppers scored 91%
so you can see the difference that the state of the art model
is at 58% and the top human
scored 91% in this exam
so when this happens, the benchmark is considered good
that there is a test in which humans are moving ahead
from LLM, so here it is very important to make LLMs work
so in that sense it was a good result
good starting point
what happened in 2023
widely adopted as a
yes basically
in 2024 it became a very good benchmark
which new models were testing and giving results
in 2024
what happened is that the results
given by frontier models
started reaching the top human baseline
and 25
this benchmark
also saturated
and slowly people stopped using it
so basically the same journey that always remains
a benchmark arrives, performs very well
in the sense that LLMs perform badly, humans perform well
then work is done on it
new generation of models come, contamination or whatever
new generation models improve on the previous generation
and while doing it comes a time where
they touch the human baseline and then all
the frontier models start clustering around the same score
you are not able to discriminate which model is better
so you have to understand that saturation has happened
and you eventually retire the benchmark
the life cycle of any benchmark is exactly the same
if we talk about the data set, here in total
there were 20 exam sections, basically 20 papers to be given
and in total there were more than 8000 questions
in English
the English papers were
SAT, LSAT,
Logic UA, Accorat,
Gau Gau English, JEC, I don't even know
which papers are these, Chinese papers were Gau Gau
these were all the papers
a typical question looks like this
there is a question, there are 4 options
2 formats were used in this, 18 out of 20 exams
the exams were taken in MCQ format
and the 2 exams were in short answer format
meaning you have to generate the answer
rather than selecting one of the given answers
so both the formats were mixed
zero short, chain of thought allowed
and the rest you can see here
the core metric, accuracy, how it was extracted
the settings, what all was there
there were 2 languages, one single average was extracted
same, all the details that we have discussed
again I would not bore you, you can go and read
but this is the main setup
if we discuss about this, what measures it was able to do
and what it was not able to do
so here an interesting point is that
the people who made this benchmark, they marketed this benchmark
as if
on the basis of the benchmark result
you can tell how capable an LLM is
in comparison to a human
think about it, you must have heard this headline in 2023
that a particular LLM scored more than a human
in the IIT GE paper
now what will come to your mind after hearing this
that LLMs have reached a very high level
this means that human intelligence has surpassed
you will be scared, think about it
when you have heard this news in the past
that an LLM scored more than a human
in IIT GE or CAT
so the first sentiment that comes to your mind is
that now there is nothing left
it has gone ahead of us, right
but actually it is not like that, here it is written that
this particular benchmark does test that
how much knowledge it has in the exam paper
but apart from this, it does not test other things
it is not testing that
how your model performs in long-horizon tasks
how it is doing multi-step reasoning
how it is using tools
basically the idea is that
beating an average test taker in an exam
does not mean that you have achieved
human intelligence
you have the knowledge to crack an exam
but apart from this, an agent or a human
can do a lot of things
this benchmark is not testing all that
which basically means that if someone puts a benchmark
that humans have been surpassed in this exam
it necessarily does not mean that
human intelligence has been surpassed
so this was the kind of dating that made it seem
that the end game has come and humans will be surpassed
they will be in everything